It’s hard to believe it’s been over three whole
months since those monsters came to town. If only
I had known back then what they were really
doing here, maybe I could have stopped it. I
don’t know how, so much of this is beyond me. What
could I have done? Even if I had known about it,
could I have stopped what happened to
all those people… Sickness, Sarkicism,
the SCP Foundation. It’s all still such a blur,
but for a while, I can still remember how I Spent
100 Days Infiltrating a Sarkic Cult.
It all began on a pretty ordinary day.
I live in a small lumber town, most of
the area is cut off from major cities,
connected only by miles and miles of winding road
through the forest. It’s a quiet rural place,
and a low-tech way of life. Our main business
has been timber, generations of tree cutters;
even in the modern age, we keep that going.
Although my home had always been off the
beaten track, we often had our fair share of
visitors. Hikers and wanderers would sometimes
stumble upon the town quite by accident,
yet be so enthralled by all the natural
beauty on offer that they’d just have to
spend a night at the only hotel in town,
the ‘Woodsman’s Lodge’, run by my friend Andreas.
That’s what we thought they were at first. Just
visitors. That’s why we welcomed them when they
arrived. Because not one of us had any idea who
these really were… what they really were. We
could never have known that they had chosen our
town specifically. They had come here on purpose.
Many of the warier among our town thought these
newcomers were strange. They were a group of five,
very obviously monied, but less obvious was their
reasons for coming here. When friendly townsfolk
tried to drum up a conversation with any of them,
they all seemed to report the same thing. That
these strangers were aloof, and each one gave
a dramatically different answer as to why they
had come to our quite little logging community.
One said their group were just sightseeing,
another said they had gotten lost. Someone else
from their group told a local man they were here
on a mission from someone called Karcist Varis,
and was rumored to have been quickly silenced
by another in the visitors’ party. But the one
thing they all seemingly agreed on was that they
wouldn’t be any trouble. They insisted on that,
in fact, and said the five of them were
just looking for somewhere to sleep. Bed
and board in exchange for cash. And so, someone
pointed them in the direction of Andreas’ hotel.
I was often there myself, not as a guest, but
helping my friend maintain the place. He’d
inherited the hotel from his family, but
it was always in need of repair. Luckily,
my background was in carpentry, and I was more
than happy to help old Andreas out. It wasn’t
one of your fancy, furnished hotels, the kind
you’d find in a big city, all slick and sleek
and owned by a big chain. It was homely, a more
bed-and-breakfast type of place. It was, anyway.
Whenever I was working over at the Woodsman’s,
I’d observe the strange group of visitors from a
distance. They didn’t seem to me like average
tourists or sightseers. To me, they looked
wealthy, very wealthy. It wasn’t hard to picture
any one of them as a politician or a businessman,
the way they dressed and carried themselves made
it pretty clear they were people of influence.
Of course, that begged the question: what on Earth
were people like that doing in a town like this?
I first got to speak with one of them after a
few days. The five newcomers were down a man,
and didn’t seem at all happy about that. The
remaining four were grumpy, looking angered
and agitated. I wondered if maybe their fifth
compatriot had left in the night, but when I asked
around town, apparently, nobody had seen him.
“Unless he’s crazy and decided to hike through
the woods on his own in the middle of
the night,” one of my friends scoffed,
after telling me that no one had even
heard any cars leaving the night before.
I decided to ask one of the visitors
when he passed me in the hallway of the
Woodsman’s Lodge, trying to broach
the topic as tactfully as I could.
“Sorry to see you’re down a man,” I told him.
He stopped in his tracks, like I’d just
caught him doing something he shouldn’t be.
“Yes, yes,” he replied, not turning around to
face me. “It’s a terrible shame. A terrible shame
indeed. But he had to leave us. It was for his own
good. He knew that. We all do.”
Following that odd encounter,
things got all the stranger the following
day. I arrived at the Woodsman’s again,
expecting to start another day of work. I’d
gotten a call from Andreas earlier that morning;
he was complaining about some kind of squelching
noise coming from the basement under the hotel,
that had only started last night. I told him
I wasn’t a plumber, but that I’d take a look.
So, imagine my surprise when I saw Andreas loading
most of his worldly possessions up into a truck
outside the front of his hotel. He excitedly
explained to me that he’d been bought out,
that the remaining four newcomers had
offered to buy the Woodsman’s on the spot.
“But that’s your family’s hotel, Andreas!” I
reminded him, as if it wasn’t already too late.
“I was never going to be able to keep it afloat
forever,” he shrugged. “When they told me how much
they were willing to pay, I couldn’t refuse.
You would have done the same, Ingvar. I have
never been offered so much money!”
This all made it very clear:
these guests were here to stay.
It had taken less than a week for me to
grow suspicious of these people. It wasn’t in my
nature to pry, but so much about them just didn’t
make any sense. They were clearly rich enough to
buy Andreas’ hotel like it was nothing, just an
ordinary everyday purchase like buying a loaf of
bread. But they were far too insular to seemingly
want to run a hotel for our friendly logging town.
It left me scratching my head over the whole
thing, making the question of what they were
really up to stick out like an unignorable
splinter. Were these just careless rich folk
with more money than sense? Had they somehow
grown disillusioned with their wealthy affluent
lifestyles and were now using this hotel to
learn how to connect with people on a more
fulfilling personal level? Or did they have
a different agenda, something else that they
were trying to hide? It turns out, they did…
I decided to formally introduce myself to the new
owners of the Woodsman’s. After all, I knew the
place well; it always needed something repairing.
Plus, if I could keep my little side job of
working there as a handyman going, then maybe
I could find out exactly what they were doing.
I was greeted by the man of their group I’d
spoken to briefly the other day, looking
at me with a scowl as I stood in the doorway.
“Hello, sir!” I greeted warmly, met with silence.
“We, uh, we met the other day?”
“What do you want?”
“Oh, well,” I continued, disarmed by the
bluntness. “I understand your group just
bought this place. I had a gentlemen’s agreement
with the last owner. I’d help him out, fix things
that need fixing. I just thought I should offer
the same service to you if you’d be interested.
Might help get this hotel up and running nice
and quick for you, so you can start making a
return on your investment.”
With that, the door was
unceremoniously slammed in my face.
At first, it certainly seemed like my
options for uncovering more about this strange
group were all but depleted. Or at least,
doing so through any legitimate means. But
just as I was reaching a desperate point
where I was considering donning a balaclava and
breaking into the hotel in the dead of night,
opportunity remerged from behind that closed door.
“We were sorry to turn you away yesterday,”
one of the other visitors apologized
somewhat insincerely. “But we would be
delighted to take you up on your offer.
Provided you accept a few… conditions.”
“Conditions?” I echoed. “What would these be?”
“We would need you to start on repairs
immediately, we want to open up the hotel’s doors
to guests in the next few days as a matter of
urgency,” he explained. “But you will need to
be discreet. Privacy is very important to us,
so we hope to maintain that for our guests.”
It all seemed like a lot of hoops to jump through,
certainly more than Andreas had given me
when he used to run the Woodsman’s. But it
felt like the right call, if it at least
got me closer to answers. In hindsight,
I should’ve turned them down…
Over the course of the next week,
things seemed to run relatively normally. I’d
be given a checklist of things to fix around
the hotel, and for the most part, just focused
purely on the tasks at hand. But whenever the
strange new owners were near, I’d try to
subtly listen in on their conversations.
They seemed to mostly talk about running the
hotel though, like they knew I was around.
A few tourists started showing up, in fact,
it seemed to get much busier than usual very
quickly. I asked one of the odd owners about
it, and he just brushed it off as the result
of their group marketing the Woodsman’s Lodge
more widely on the Internet. I didn’t see much
of the hotel’s guests, staying out of
their way as I had been instructed to.
But it did strike me as odd how few of them
seemed to leave. Some I spotted around town,
usually those traveling as a couple or in a
larger group. Any that were staying alone though,
they didn’t seem to venture beyond the Woodsman’s.
None of them checked out either, but their rooms
would be empty, and often needed repairs –
mainly scratch marks on the wooden floorboards.
Two and a half weeks after the weird group
had arrived and bought up my friend’s hotel,
I got a call from someone I knew who
lived next door to the Woodsman’s.
“The hotel, someone was screaming!”
she said frantically over the line.
“Get here quick, they might need you!”
I checked the time; it was the dead of night,
so late that it was almost the start of the
next day. Racing quickly over to the hotel,
I was greeted by one of the owners. He had rushed
to the door, wide awake like he hadn’t even been
sleeping. When I told him there were reports
of blood-curdling screams, he reprimanded me.
“You were told, our guests’ privacy must be
maintained!” he scolded. “If you must know,
one of the hikers staying with us tripped over
and had a nasty fall. He landed downstairs,
in the basement, and he’s in a lot of pain, not
to be moved. We’ve called for an ambulance.”
I wanted to take what he had said at face value,
but the fact he wouldn’t let me in to see the
injured man felt suspicious. I spent the night
with the person who lived next door to the hotel,
watching the Woodsman’s Lodge for any sign
of an ambulance. It never arrived. That was
when I remembered: he had said the guest
fell into the basement. The same basement
Andreas had heard a strange squelching
coming from. And not once had these new
owners asked me to take a look down there…
Already I was even further suspicious of the
new owners now. I had no idea what they were
up to, the wild theories in my head ranged
from them being a group of sadistic serial
killers using the hotel to lure victims, or a
shadowy government black ops team up to something
nefarious. Enough was enough, I needed answers.
I couldn’t wait for an opportunity, I had to
create one. While as few people were in the hotel
as possible, I snuck into the main office. Not
to steal anything or even peek just yet, but to
break the legs off a desk; if they asked me to
fix it, then I would be able to spend longer
in the office with no supervision. Sure enough,
they soon asked me I’d be able to fix the desk,
and that was my in. I started rummaging through
the filing cabinets, rifling through whatever
I could find. Old expenses reports, legal
documents left behind by Andreas, but there
was nothing that could give me any inkling as
to what was actually going on. Until there was…
You see, as much as it came as a surprise
to no one more than me, I wasn’t the only
one looking into this strange group…
One of the guests entered the office
and quickly realized what he was doing. At
first, he seemed to imply that I was somehow
in league with the new owners. But I was able
to talk him around, telling him I just wanted
to try to get to the bottom of what they were up
to. That was when he revealed to me who he was.
“Agent Clericson,” he introduced himself.
“I’m here on behalf of the SCP Foundation.”
After he brought me up to speed on what the
hell that all meant, we arranged to reconvene
somewhere they wouldn’t overhear us. Meeting up
at the lumber mill, he explained that these four
strangers were a cult, a subsect of a strange
religion I had never heard of called Sarkicism.
But after Agent Clericson described
their practices, I wouldn’t soon forget;
ritualistic sacrifices, cannibalism,
and even far, far worse than that…
it made me feel sick just hearing about it.
Over the next few days, Clericson agreed to
let me help in his investigation, offering me the
chance to help the Foundation and make it so that
nobody in my remote little logging town would ever
have to suffer the memory of what the Sarkic cult
were up to. Little did I realize he also meant me.
I did my best to spy on the death and disease
worshipping cultists without drawing too much
suspicion and reported my findings back to the
Foundation agent. But it quickly became clear
that he was unimpressed with my current method
of just eavesdropping, so instead, he suggested a
more direct approach. Clericson gave me a book on
the Sarkic religion, telling me to memorize as
much as I could and then approach the cultists
as if I shared in their twisted beliefs.
Even reading the teachings of Grand Karcist
Ion was enough to make my stomach turn. All
the grotesque things that the founder of this
cult’s beliefs preached in order to achieve
something akin to godhood… it was horrific.
What was much more horrific, though, was that our
plan went awry. I asked to speak alone with one of
the cultists, and instantly started explaining
that I had observed them for a time and come
to realize that we were one and the same. In a
state of panic, I regurgitated anything I could
still remember from reading about Sarkicism,
their goal to achieve apotheosis through will,
the consumption of gods, and… sacrifice. But
I must have said something wrong; one of them
snuck up behind me and knocked me unconscious.
I woke up in a daze, a splitting headache running
through my skull. I was in a cage, in a part
of the hotel I hadn’t seen before. It was dark,
absent of natural light. There were others
too, I recognized one or two of the hotel’s
single guests, also trapped in cages.
Agent Clericson was nowhere to be found.
The Sarkic cultists spent the next day asking
me how I had found them. I told them the truth,
and answered their questions the only way I
knew how, but I couldn’t make them believe me.
“Liar!” one spat. “You did your homework, I’ll
admit. But the Foundation is known for working in
broad strokes, missing out on the finer details.”
“We’re Neo-Sarkites,” another explained. “You
were spouting the teachings of the
Proto-Sarkic religion. We believe
the only way of becoming a god, achieving
the apotheosis, is through sheer will.”
“And in terms of sacrifice,” one of
the other cultists chimed in. “We’ll
sacrifice many in service of us few. But
you’ll soon come to witness more of that.”
They kept me in the cage for days, without food
and barely any water. I felt so drained of energy
before long, and I soon realized why no one
had heard the captive guests calling out for
help. They were so weak that they could
barely gather enough strength to shout,
and those that did, their voices were too
weak to reach anyone above the basement.
The cultists came and went all throughout the
day, alternating between running the Woodsman’s
Lodge and coming down into the dark, cramped
and disgusting room below. The stench was foul,
yet not one of the Sarkic cultists seemed to
mind. They would just talk endlessly about the
‘new age of Flesh’, before dragging
their next victim out of their cage
at night and taking them into a back room.
By this point, all the remaining hotel guests
that had been caged up with me were gone. I could
never fully see what went on in the other room,
but I certainly heard a lot. There were
muffled screams, followed by chanting
in a language I didn’t understand. Then
came the noise of something slithering,
all the while the cultists – who had gathered in
the room with their captive victim – kept reciting
their incantations. I had no idea what was going
on in there, but the hotel guests never remerged,
just the Sarkites. I had read enough about
their rituals to get a pretty good idea…
I had lost track of how long I’d been held
prisoner when Agent Clericson appeared in
the basement. The cultists’ backs had been
turned just long enough for him to slip
downstairs undetected. For a moment, I thought
I was saved, only for my heart to sink when he
told me he couldn’t get me out. I pleaded
with him, but he insisted that he needed to
know exactly what was going on down here. As he
left me on my own, I cursed him under my breath.
Before much longer, the cultists decided it was
my turn. They dragged me out of my cage and into
the back room, strapping me to a chair. I had no
strength left to fight back, but I had plenty of
fear. There were more cages back here, it was
an old storeroom that they were now keeping…
nightmares in. The things in the cages were
disgusting abominations, masses of bloody, gooey
flesh… flesh that had once been human. I realized
these were the hotel guests, the ones who traveled
alone, who never checked out… whose fingernails
had left scratches on the floorboards as they
were dragged out of their rooms by the cultists.
Using a cattle prod, one of the Sarkites started
directing a creature towards me. The horrible
mutant was getting closer, an appendage resembling
an arm reaching out at me. It was going to
turn me into one of them, and I couldn’t stop
it. Scared for my life, I mustered the little
energy I had left to try and pull away from
the sickening creature, but just as it was about
to make contact… someone kicked down the door.
Agent Clericson had returned with reinforcements,
members of a Mobile Task Force that promptly
arrested the Sarkic cultists and sealed the room
containing the monsters for the time being. He sat
down next to me and explained what had gone on,
but I was barely awake enough to keep up with all
the details. Something about “SCP-610 instances”
and “rare to see them this far out of Siberia”.
But he promised that the SCP Foundation would be
ordering the creatures to be incinerated soon.
The Woodsman’s lodge would have to be
burned down as part of the cover story.
As for me, I just want to forget the whole ordeal.
The Sarkic cult, all the people they turned into
monsters, the horrifying things they do, the
SCP-610s. All of it, I want it all gone. Luckily,
Agent Clericson has given me something he says
will help with that. He called it an amnestic…
Want an anomaly of your own? Check out
www.scpswag.com for high-quality SCP merch!
Now go and check out “WHAT DOES THIS SECRET SCP
RELIGION BELIEVE IN?” and “I SURVIVED 100 DAYS
HIDING FROM THE SCP FOUNDATION... HERE’S WHAT
HAPPENED” for more mysterious SCP offerings!